Let I see. McKenzie is very aggressively saying
that they were not given a full opportunity.
You are on right now, McKenzie. Did you
have something you wanted to talk about?
Yes, I apologize. I had the thing deafened. So.
All right. Very good. What can we do for you? So
I just had a question. I'm not sure. We talked
about this before. Is that important to you?
I'm Jewish, too. And I was just wondering what
your observation is on anti-Semitism on the left.
So I've been interested in, like the online world
for a while and I feel a bit shut out because
it just seems like people are denying that Jews
are also indigenous to the region and saying that
they dislike Zionists. But the vast majority of
American Jews overall are Zionist. And I feel
like there are a lot of double standards
with, you know, saying Israel is not real.
But then also, you know, not having
a problem with like Lebanon or Egypt
when it was created by the British mandate to.
Yeah. So there's a lot I mean, these are all
different issues. So there's the there's the
geopolitical in terms of one's opinion about
Middle East politics. That's one thing I think.
And there are very healthy debates to be had
there. I think, you know, we're very familiar
with how right wing anti-Semitism manifests in
the United States and people on the left tend to
understand that and sort of up call it out. There
is, unfortunately, left wing anti-Semitism as
well, which takes on a different tone and tenor.
It includes sort of writing off oppression
and discrimination against Jewish people,
which has been a constant around the world for
thousands of years. There is the sort of writing
Jews off in the United States as privileged whites
when that completely ignores that. But basically,
all European discrimination against Jews over
the last hundred years is predicated on the
idea that Jews are not indeed considered white.
We saw the women's march stuff where Jewish women
were not considered intersectional enough to be
part of the leadership of the women's march. So
there is a lot of left wing anti-Semitism.
It's more I don't want to call it nuance,
because that almost makes it sound good. It's
it's more hidden. And I think that's that's
where I would sort of put it. But yes, left
and right wing anti-Semitism both exist. They
are different things. They look different.
And I've been talking about it for years.
Yeah. So I was just wondering. So I just feel
like it's becoming more of an bigger issue.
So with the DSA, like it's a fairly
large socialist left wing organization.
Yeah. And I just feel like they
also have been writing off.
You know, anti-Semitism or like ignoring,
you know, Jewish perspective on Israel,
for example, and I know that I know less about
because as someone who is not a socialist,
I don't really do or I don't observe DSA or
know too much about it. So I wouldn't be able
to really say anything about that.
OK. Gotcha. Yeah. Thank you.
And I also just wanted to share my opinion
on the Jenny Harrison versus Lindsey Graham
race, too, because I am from South Carolina.
Yeah. Real quick. Yeah. I just feel like a lot of
I think Lindsey Graham is going
to win 90 percent of the chance.
I think it's gonna happen.
I just feel like there's not enough
long term hype about Jenny Harrison.
Yeah, I mean, if you again, if you force me to
bet, I bet Graham wins. But I think it'll be
close enough that there's certainly that Jamie
Harrison certainly has a shot. And it would be
amazing to defeat Lindsey Graham. I totally agree,
you know. All right, McKenzie, great to hear from
McKenzie from South Carolina. That is all the
time I have today. So if people are still holding,
I do. And I grovel at your feet that I
will be unable to get to anymore today.
But there will be streams where there may
be opportunities to call in. We will go to a
break on the podcast. The TV show and the radio
show and be back with plenty more momentarily.